ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนตอนเย็นค่ะน้องก็ไม่เจอกับเรา
2 คนอีกแล้วมาหาในชั่วโมงดีกินเนอะ
เนื้อใช่ค่ะในช่องคอมเพลงสิเบอร์ไทยใช่
มั้ยในแล้วน้องก็คือฟ้าครับวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธเนาะวันพุธ
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 8 ค่ะ
ดีเดือนเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีและขอ
สค2 2021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
อังคารที่ 7
เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีคศ 2  021 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันพฤหัสที่ 9 ค่ะเดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 12 ค่ะค่ะดีผชปี
2564 ปีคศ
2  021 ค่ะ
วันนี้เป็นวันพุธนะหาวันพุธแล้วแล้วตอน
นี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลาบ่าย
โมง 17 นาทีค่ะ 13:00 น 17 นาที
แล้วก็พระอาทิตย์จะใหญ่มากนะคะก็ต้องร้อน
ต้องหักอาจจะซัก
32 องศาเซลเซียสเนาะว่าตอนนี้เป็นเดือน
ธันวาคมต่อร้อนนิดหน่อยยังโอเค lk ไม่ใช่
ไหมแต่นะเรียนนะประเทศไทยหน้าร้อนมีพระ
อาทิตย์ใหญ่ๆนักเรียนชอบร้อนหรอคะเห้ย
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบร้อนไม่ตอบใช่ไหมเพราะว่าครู
ฟ้าครูหญิงน่ะมันไม่ใช่ผู้หญิง
คนไทยคนไทยเนี่ยเวลาคิดอ่ะประเทศไทยหรือ
นักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยร้านนักเรียนเนี่ย
ได้ยิน
Thailand ประเทศไทยในก็คิดก็ร้อน
หนังถูกต้อง
ร้อนเลยประเทศไทยเนี่ยใช่มั้ยพระอาทิตย์
ใหญ่
ใหญ่มากร้อนอาจจะซัก
38 องศาเซลเซียสใช่ไหมคะร้อนๆ
โป้นักเรียนก็จะรู้จักรู้จักประเทศไทย
ร้อน
รู้จักประเทศไอร้อนอย่างเดียวหรอนักเรียน
มากมายเพราะว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีดีเยอะ
ๆไม่ใช่แค่ร้อง
ไม่ใช่แม่ร้อนนะคะยังมีอย่างอื่นด้วย
ใช่
มีอะไรบ้างครับประเทศไทยเนี่ยประเทศไทย
หรอก็มีทะเล
อะไรก็จะเป็นเกาะล้อเกาะมีต้นมะพร้าวใช่
มั้ยมีต้นมะพร้าว
เป็นเกาะแล้วก็มีน้ำทะเลอ่ะจะมีปลาฉลาม
ใช่ไหมคะทะเลไปเป็นเกาะหรือว่าทะเลทะเล
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเวลาดูเนี่ยว่า
ว่า
สวย
นักเรียนชอบไหมทะเลประเทศไทย
ชอบนักเรียนเนี่ยเวลาได้ยินประเทศไทยนัก
เรียนรู้จักทะเลผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีรูปให้ดู
ด้วยนะสู่ฟ้า
งูทะเลในไทยใช่ไหมคะทายค่ะนี่คือนี้
ที่ไหนคะเนี่ยพัทยาหรือเปล่าไม่ใช่น่ะไม่
ใสพัทยา
อันนี้นั้นจะเป็น True เกศน้องเกาะดี
สวยไหมสวยมากทะเลเนี่ยสีเขียวเลยนะคะ
ทะเลสีเขียวนี่ก็ประเทศไทยนะทะเลไทย
ทะเลไทยสวยมากตายนักเรียนอยู่เลยบ่
ว้าวสวยมากจะไม่ทะเลไทยแล้วคุณครูฟ้า
เนี่ยคิดนะกูฟ้าคิดๆๆว่านักเรียนเนี่ยรู้
จักอะไรประเทศไทยอีกที่ไม่ใช่แค่ทะเลแล้ว
ก็ร้อน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่านักเรียนรู้จัก
อาหารไทยค่ะโห
อาหารไอใช่ไหมเพราะว่าอ่าประเทศไทยเนี่ย
มีทะเลแล้วก็อาหารไทยที่อร่อยมากตายในรูป
นี้ก็คืออาหารไทยอันนี้อะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าเห็น
ไหมแอดผัดไข่ใช่ไหมคะไก่ขาดผัดไทยยังไง
ส้มตำตาตำแกงเขียวหวานต้มยำกุ้ง
ข้าวกระเพราไข่ดาว
ไก่ผัดเม็ดมะม่วงก็ต้องหิมพานต์กูอย่าวะ
แกงมัสมั่นแล้วก็เข้าเหนียวมะม่วงก็ถ้า
ทั้งหมดนี้คืออาหารไทย
ใช่ค่ะทั้งหมดคืออาหารไทยกินลิๆนักเรียน
เนี่ยเวลาแบบประเทศไทย
อาหารไทยใช่มั้ยนักเรียนรู้จักอาหารไทย
คิดว่านักเรียนรู้จักอาหารไทยทั้งหมดไหม
ต้มยำกุ้งนักเรียนรู้จักหน้าข้าวเหนียว
มะม่วง
ไทย
นักเรียนอาจจะรู้จักแล้วก็
กินแล้ว
อร่อยมากอาหารไทยแบบนี้
อร่อยมากใช่คิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนก็น่าจะ
ชอบประเทศไทยแต่ว่าอาหารไทยนะใส่สักครู
ฟ้าก็ช่อประเทศไทยเพราะว่าอาหารไทยนะคะ
นี่
รอบอาหารไทยที่สุดจ่ายนักเรียนเนี่ยรู้
จักประเทศไทยก็จะมีอาหารไทยหายทะเลไทย
มีอะไรอีกที่นักเรียนรู้จักครูฟ้าคิดผู้
หญิงก่อนแล้วกันนะเอาคู่หญิงคิดว่ามีทะเล
แล้วใช่ไหมครูฟ้าถ้าประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็มีภู
เขา
รักภูเขาภูเขาที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็สวย
ว้าวเหมือนกัน
จริงหรอคือ 1 อัตราได้ยินว่าทะเลสวยแต่ภู
เขาก็สวยหรอคะใช่ค่ะนี่
เสือภูเขาประเทศไทยนะคะ
กินมั้ยเป็นภูเขาภูเขาภูเขาสวยไหมสวยมาก
ค่ะที่นั่นอันนี้เนี่ยอยู่ภาคเหนือค่ะ
แล้วผู้หญิงวาดแผนที่ประเทศไทยก่อนนะ
อันนี้แบบป่าวแอ๊บแตกหน่อยนะคะนี่ประเทศ
ไทยเนาะอันนี้ภาคใต้นะคะ
น้านี่ค่ะอยู่ภาคเหนือของประเทศไทย
หวยหัวเหมือนเนี่ยอากาศดีนะคะช้าใช่อัน
นี้ก็ภูเขาภาคเหนือเหมือนกันๆหาง
สวยมากภูเขาประเทศไทยก็สวย
ภูเขาร้อนไหมคะผู้หญิงไม่ร้อนหน้า
หนาวสบายๆๆ
ดี
สายค่ะใช้ภูมินักเรียนก็อาจจะรู้จักเนาะ
ภูเขาที่ประเทศไทยว่า
สวยในอะภูเขาภาคเหนือภาคเหมือนป่ะเออพัด
ใต้
นักเรียนแล้วไปดูหลายๆที่ได้
แล้วนะๆก็รู้จักว่าอ้อประเทศไทยอาหาร
อร่อยเหอะทะเลสวยภูเขาสวยนะมีอะไรอีก
เรื่องคิดว่านักเรียนน่าจะรู้จัก
มวยไทยไหมคะอ๋อ
มวยไทย
มวยคันนี่คือมวยไทยนี้หนู
มีผู้ชายมีผู้ชายสองคนอร่อยใช่ไหมคะเราก็
เตะเลยคนนี้แหละกำลังเตะมวยไทย
นักเรียนชอบดูมวยไทยหรอคะเออเข้าไปนัก
เรียนคิดว่านะคิดว่านักเรียนนักเรียนชอบ
ดูมวยไทยแล้วก็รู้จักเพราะเห็นมวยไทยปุ๊บ
นักเรียนคิดประเทศไทย
เข้าใจประเทศไทย
ผู้หญิงหอยมวยได้ไหมคะ
ก่อนต่อยได้ก่อนนิ่งตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆชุด
ว่าผู้หญิงจะมาคุยอึ้งหญิง
สาวผู้หญิงเนี่ยน่าจะอายุประมาณ
10 ขวบ
10 ขวบบ่เคยเรียนด้วย
[เพลง]
เด็กฟรีฟ้าต่อยมวยได้ไหมคะครูฟ้าต่อยมวย
ไม่ได้หาไม่เคยเรียนนะฮะไม่เคยไม่เคย
เรียนต่อยมวยแต่
ชอบดูนะชอบอะไรมึงถ้าคนต่อยมวยอะไรอย่าง
นี้ไงมากสนุกใช่มั้ยมวยไทยแล้วก็เป็นแบบ
ไทยๆต้องไปไข่ก็เป็นแบบไทยใช่ไหมที่อื่น
ไม่มี Thailand ประเทศไทยเท่านั้น
[เพลง]
นั่นแหละก็เลยคิดว่านักเรียนก็รู้จัก
ประเทศไทยรู้จักมวยไทยต่ายค่ะ
แล้วก็มีอะไรประเทศไทยยิงคิดว่าประเทศไทย
มีอีกอย่างนึง
มีอะไรกันเนี่ยต้องรู้จักๆอ้ะวัด
ฮึ
ดีสุนัขนักเรียนชายค่ะ
วัดวัดที่ประเทศอาทิวัดนะคะเวนิว
วัชนา
แต่ถ้าวัดที่ประเทศไทยถ้านักเรียนนัก
เรียนเนี่ยคิดอยากมาประเทศไทยนักเรียนจะ
ต้องไปดูวัดพระนักเรียนรู้จักวัดสมัยนี่
คิดว่ารู้จักมากๆก็คือนี้เลย Grand
Palace นะคะหรือว่าวัดพระแก้วสมัยอันนี้
แหละกรุงเทพฯไหม
สวยมากๆ
ว้าววัดละหารอีนักเรียนมาประเทศไทยนัก
เรียนก็ไปอยู่วัด
ไปวัดใช่ไหมอ่ะอันนี้ก็วัดนะฮะวัดที่
ประเทศไทยเหมือนกันโห่กรุงเทพฯใช่ไหมคะ
กรุงเทพฯค่ะอันนี้ก็อยู่กรุงเทพนะนี้เรา
จะเรียกว่าเป็น mabo  Temple น้องเป็นวัด
หินอ่อนสวยมากสุด
เทพสมัยวัดน้าแต่ประเทศไทยท้ายบทมีวัด
เวลานักเรียนเนี่ยได้ยินประเทศไทยนั้นก็
จะรู้จักก็อ้าว
วัดวัดรหัสวัด
ก็มามาได้นะคะเป็น
คริสต์ก็ได้ใช่มั้ยจ่าย in อิสลามก็ได้
เป็นกล้องหลีกเข้ามาได้จ่ายไปดูใช่มั้ยดู
เท่านั้น
สวยๆ
โอ้
นี่ไหนอ่ะฟ้าผู้หญิงเวลานักเรียนมาประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยคิดว่านักเรียนน่าจะ
คิดถึงทางไหมคะตอบแปร
ช้างเนื้อหักค่านี่ค่า
ช้าง
นี่ขาไทยนะเสื้อให้ช้างไทยให้ไม่ใช่
แอฟริกาจะไม่ใช่แอฟริกาไม่เหมือนกันวิธี
อินเดียนี่อื่นช้างไทยในประเทศไทยมีช้าง
ก็จะรู้จักประเทศไทยช้าง
สาขางานนักเรียนอาจจะมาแล้วก็นั่งตาค้าง
สไลด์นี้เป็นสาง
จะมาแล้วก็นักเรียนม
เขานางสาง
โอ้วมีใคร
ออกผู้หญิงเคยนั่งช้างไหมคะ
ไม่ไม่เคยน้อยครูหญิงแล้วก็ที่นี่อ่ะไม่
เคยครูฟ้าล่ะครูบาก็ไม่เคยแต่นักเรียนใช่
ไหมนักเรียนอำเภอเห็นแล้วก็มาประเทศไทย
ประเทศไทยมีช้างนั่งช้างที่ประเทศไทยดูดู
ช้างประเทศไทยมีประเทศไทยมีช้างเยอะนะคะ
มีช้างให้กูเยอะนักเรียนไล่หนูก็มีช้าง
อยู่ไหมไปกรุงเทพมีช้างไหมไม่มีต้องไป
เชียงใหม่เชียงใหม่ใส่แต่ว่านอกจากช้าง
แล้วเนี่ยผู้หญิงคิดว่ามีอีกอย่างนึงที่
นักเรียนเนี่ยมารู้จักเกี่ยวกับประเทศไทย
นั่นคืออะไรคะผู้หญิงให้ฟ้าเนี่ยบอกว่า
ว่ามีอาหารไทยใช่ไหมอาหารไทยแล้วมันก็
ต้องมีอันนี้ด้วยค่ะครูฟ้าอะไรคะ
ผลไม้ไทยโอ้ยคนละม้ายใคร
หายทุเรียนทุเรียน
นี่ค่ะทุเรียนไข่
เออมี
รถใช่มั้ยสับปะรดส้มโอ
งอๆเมื่อไหร่อดบังคุดอันนี้นะคะกล้วยแล้ว
ก็อันนี้นักเรียนชอบมาก
มะม่วงหา
มะม่วงหรือว่าแตงโมไหมอันนี้ไม่มีแตงโม
ยืดนะ
โรงเรียนน่าจะตกแต่งโบว์ไทยนะคะจ่ายค่ะ
โมโนโบ้นะกันโมใช้เป็นผลไม้ไทยในนักเรียน
อยากรู้จักก็ประเทศไทยมีผลไม้
ต้องแล้วประเทศไทยมีผลไม้เยอะเราไม้ให้
ผลไม้พืชไม้นะคะมีไม้ให้นักเรียนกินตลอด
เลยสมัย 12 เดือน
12 เดือนประเทศไทยมีผลไม้
เหนื่อยแล้วเนี่ยเวลานักเรียนแนะได้ยิน
ประเทศไทยนักเรียนก็จะรู้จักใช่ไหม
ทะเลไทย
[เพลง]
ภูเขา
อาหารไทย
มวยไทยเลยค่ะ
Wat  U
ท้างค่ะ
คนละไม้แล้วก็อีกหนึ่งยังอะไรเขาหญิงภาษา
ไทย
ลงภาษาไทยสมัยถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอ
คอมเพลสเซอร์เบิ้ลไทยก็แปลว่านักเรียน
เนี่ยรู้จักภาษาไทยชอบภาษาไทยใช่ไหมคะ
สวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณค่ะอร่อยภาษาไทยและนัก
เรียนก็จะต้องรู้จักครูไทยใช่ไหมลูก
อินดูเอกรูหลายๆคนน่ากลัวชายที่เราใช่ไหม
สอนภาษาไทยอ่ะจะอ่านไม่ได้เนาะแต่ว่านี่
คือพาชื่อภาษาไทยใช้ภาษาไทยเป็น
ABC นิภาษาอังกฤษ
ไม่เอา
ภาษาไทย
ภาษาไทยทั้งหมดเนาะนักเรียนเนี่ยต้องรู้
จักภาษาไทยอ่ะรู้จักว่าสวัสดีค่ะใส่คนไทย
ไว้แล้วก็ชอบสวัสดีค่ะ
ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะ
ก็ถ้านักเรียนรู้จักอะไรประเทศไทยอีกก็
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้
เลยหาแล้วก็เจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียน
สาถ้าชอบก็อย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด
Subscribe นะคะใจแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
ม 6 ต